you invite your friends over plug in the
Rolly crack a couple eggs you just chat
while you're waiting for your eggs
cylinder to extrude I don't know what
we're doing what are we doing for
something with eggs there's an egg
machine egg - I can't wait to get some
to be eggs all up in this business this
also looks like one of those things that
is marketed as a cooking device but is
in fact a sex toy in disguise why else
would it need a textured no-slip grip
apparently I'd have to spray a little
bit of this joint in here and then I get
a nice delicious egg glove oh all right
I really hope their instructions I'm
pretty sure I just like [ __ ] slam it in
right hey why god it's bubbling which is
also a great visual for eggs I feel like
I'm peering over one of those eggs from
alien so the egg was really hopping
around in there but now it seems to have
calmed down
it's quivering again there's a little I
of the hurricane and now it's back at it
there's very little clear liquid left so
I think we're getting to the point where
it's almost cooked through oh yeah here
it comes
I mean I wish all my food did this
[Music]
no no don't you die on me well wait it's
like the tide I think it's gonna return
ready for this breakfast this is what
people want now this is how people want
to live their lives the way that the
yoke is separated from the whites is
very phallic I hate how long it is but I
would not want it to be any girthier
you have this with a sausage patty and
it's like a weird fucked-up breakfast
for their trading shapes divorced from
the imagery it really just does taste
like an egg listen has science gone too
far definitively yes this is a future
technology and it really should be
pushing the limits of what culinary
worlds will allow let's go for three
eggs
top it off okay it's filled up to the
top it's bubbling that's good
we might get some extruding happening oh
yeah things are lifting yes come to life
oh oh oh god it's just shooting right
back up this will this part looks like a
slimy egg banana pretty smart and I bite
cat why not
Camden bye
[Music]